[Music]
well obviously we can control
minds
you don't need to have implants and
technology embedded in the brain
or things inside our heads
i'm talking now and it's affecting
everyone who's listening
affecting their brains and perhaps
affecting how they're thinking
that's happening all the time and we can
control minds in
through persuasion i mean the whole
advertising industry is based on
controlling minds through persuasion
we can control minds through hypnosis
which is perhaps more scary sometimes
and even when there are direct devices
implanted in the brain and i suppose
that happens most commonly now with
cochlear
implants people have to learn how to
use these and the cochlear implant
doesn't directly control their mind it
allows electrical impulses to go into
the brain tissue
and people have to take months learning
how to interpret these
there's a way in where we've already got
widespread
thousands maybe millions of people have
these devices
but our minds also i think were reach
out and affect
uh people uh at a distance uh directly
perhaps in the more almost
not like uraguella but one of the areas
i've done research on
is on telepathic influences on dogs
dogs much more sensitive than people uh
it turns out and many people have dogs
that know when they're coming home
and go created a door or window and
this is something which is it's not just
coincidence we did lots of experiments
this is in peer-reviewed journals with
videotaped evidence um we videoed the
place the dog waits
and the persons then called and told
when to go home at a randomly chosen
time they don't know in advance
they travel in a taxi to avoid any
familiar car sounds or smells
and over and over again the dog goes and
starts waiting at the door
while they're on the way home and
massively significant statistically
there's an example i think of something
that's still not properly understood
telepathy is very common
telephone teleport is the commonest
human kind you think of someone
and then shortly afterwards they ring
you say that's funny i was just thinking
about you
or you know who it is when the phone
rings and again i've done lots of
experiments on that
where there are four callers you have to
choose which
we choose which of the four makes the
call at random
they call the person they know it's one
of these four people they have to guess
who it is
before they answer the phone no caller
id
and the results are way above the 25
chance level they average about 45
percent in our film tests with a
massively
uh significant result so i think there's
already evidence that minds
are actually much more than just the
brain they can be influenced by all
sorts of things psychedelic drugs
persuasion
other people's words torture hypnosis
can change our minds and influence them
but our minds can also
have effects at a distance as shown in
telephone telepathy
and on the way they influence dogs at a
distance
and this has nothing to do with
technology i think it may have some
niche applications
but obviously we're going to have to
talk more about minds and how they work
you